ja mein Thema sind kaputt gesparte
Kinderkliniken und wird unser Klinik
Wesen unsere klinik-landschaft
eigentlich eine Gefahr für Leib und
Leben
und was wir gerade erleben wir hatten es
in der corona-pandemie den
Ausnahmezustand in den Kliniken wir
haben ihn jetzt wieder der RS Virus an
der Arten rx-kranken die jetzt wieder um
sich schlägt zeigt dass wir über Jahre
und Jahrzehnte und ich glaube da darf
sich auch keine Partei aus der
Verantwortung wirklich spielen das
Kliniken komplett ramponiert haben und
die Antworten die wir jetzt geben immer
noch sehr kurzfristig sind ich hoffe
dass zumindest das was heute auf dem Weg
gebracht wurde zumindest auf Bundesebene
ähm erste Schritte in die richtige
Richtung sind aber wenn ich mir
anschauen was wir in den Ländern zum
Teil treiben wie kaputt wir die Pflege
sparen wie wir weniger attraktiv die
Berufe machen dann befürchtestes für uns
allein schon wegen der demografischen
Entwicklungen in unserem Land
kaputt gespart was muss jetzt passieren
dass wir sicherstellen können das
schwerstkranke Kinder das Kinder die
eine Intensivbetreuung brauchen dass die
auch wirklich behandelt werden jede
zweite Klinik habe ich Appetit muss
Kinder von der Intensivstation derzeit
ablehnen teilweise werden Kinder 40
Kilometer in andere Kliniken Gefahren
Kinder die nur hohes Fieber haben werden
sowieso gleich mal abgewiesen das ist
die Situation unerträglich die Situation
was wir jetzt zuerst mal brauchen ist
wieder eine Übernahme von Verantwortung
und diese Verantwortung vermisse ich
momentan schmerzlich insbesondere bei
den Landesministern also wenn ich hier
an die Gesundheitssenatorin im Land
Berlin denke die mehr in Kassel
angeblich Wald als in Berlin dann ist es
erschreckend und wir hatten jetzt eine
Brandbrief ganz aktuell zu dieser
Thematik die Pädiatrie ist völlig
überlastet sowohl im stationären als
auch im ambulanten Bereichen
haben sie angesprochen das war schon der
zweite dort wird hier in Berlin und
Treffen mit der Gesundheitssenatorin die
Grundproblematik ist wir versuchen jetzt
natürlich ganz schnell gewisse Maßnahmen
zu ergreifen gemischte Teams z.B das
jetzt sowohl die Kinderpflege als auch
von normalen Fliegerinnen und Fliegern
oder Krankenpflegerinnen und Pflegern
unterstützte aber das ist ja alles nicht
die Dauer so wenn ich mir anschaue wir
haben 600 Plätze für Kinder in ganz
Deutschland verteilt im Krankenhaus
Wesen wir können nur 360 Plätze davon
belegen weil wir das Personal haben nur
für 360 Plätze haben das ist natürlich
eine riesen Herausforderung an die
Struktur und gleichzeitig führen wir
hier eine Diskussion zum Beispiel im
Land Berlin wo Studierende der Pflege
keine Vergütung für ihren Praxiseinsatz
bekommen wir lassen jetzt im Land Berlin
wieder 1,6 Millionen Euro verfallen weil
die Senatsverwaltung nicht in die
Umsetzung kommt und damit brauche ich
mich natürlich nicht wundern wenn sich
jemand nicht für den Pfleger als Beruf
entscheidet natürlich das ist ja nicht
das Problem nur alleine in der
Hauptstadt sondern man kann sagen in
ganz Deutschland wieder ein Skandal also
und vor allem einer der absehbar war
also wenn wir jetzt mal über die Länder
Grenzen hinaus Skandinavien die haben
auch früher geöffnet und so weiter also
da hat sich das ja gezeigt die haben das
gleiche Problem da hätte man natürlich
vorbauen müssen und natürlich sie haben
es angesprochen das ist eine hilfslösung
dass man jetzt auch sehr
erwachsenenpflege in die Kinderpflege
weil es so ganz anders ist ja also da
braucht im Zweifel natürlich eine andere
Pflege aber irgendwas muss man tun wenn
man heute Karl Lauterbach hat getwittert
dass das Kinder keine Hilfe mehr in
cleaning bekommen Katastrophe wenn das
ein Bundesgesundheitsminister sagt dann
muss man gleichzeitig noch einen anderen
Satz dazu sagen also das ist schon und
auch hier bitte also man hat auch den
Eindruck er nimmt dann immer die Gruppe
die gerade besonders betroffen ist und
und schiebt die nach vorne statt was zu
tun ja weil das natürlich ein erster
sehr lange auch schon im Gesundheit eine
Gesundheitspolitik ad hoc ist das immer
schwierig denn wo kriegt man jetzt das
Personal her ja das heißt wir haben
jetzt akutes Problem aber es war
absehbar und man hat gewartet und jetzt
420 Millionen Euro ja werden zur
Verfügung gestellt muss immer erst hat
man den Eindruck der Notfall in
Deutschland ausbrechen damit dann die
Politik reagieren man könnte fast den
Eindruck haben das stimmt ich glaube den
meisten ist gar nicht klar die ist ja
immer auch in der corona-pandemie die
Zahl der Pflege geht zurück bei alle den
Beruf verlassen wegen überarbeitungszeit
der Fall gewesen selbst in der cor der
Pandemie ist die Zahl der Pflegekräfte
in Deutschland man glaubt es kaum aber
laut Statistik der Bundesagentur für
Arbeit sogar leicht gestiegen und wir
haben das auch jetzt wieder gesehen bei
der Zahl derjenigen die eine
Lehrausbildung machen wollen für diesen
Pflegeberuf dieser Beruf ist schon sehr
attraktiv und deswegen kann ich
verstehen dass man da auch jetzt auf der
Pfleger ist attraktiv naja es gibt
es gibt kaum eine Berufsgruppe die ein
so dramatisches Lohn Plus in den letzten
10 Jahren gehabt hat
wir können das alles beklagen das ist
richtig wir müssen aber auch immer
wissen bei allem wenn wir über das
Gesundheitssystem schimpfen wir müssen
alle bezahlen der Lohn und das müssen
wir mal sagen wenn wir wenn wir und ich
will damit keine keine kritische
Situation klein reden bloß ich stimme
mich so ein bisschen daran zu sagen
hätten alles wissen müssen und wie kann
es sein dass wir müssen das alles wissen
wir halten also dann ähm das wir müssen
auch was wir dann auf was wir dann
verzichten wollen denn ein
Gesundheitssystem vorzuhalten wie das
haben aktuell eins der teuersten der
Welt in Deutschland das bezahlen wir im
nächsten Jahr als Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitgeber mit den höchsten
Sozialbeiträgen aller Zeiten für Rente
für Krankenkassen und so weiter und
sofort verwunderlicher wenn wir jetzt
mit Kindern also das ist es ist tragisch
und es ist unglaublich dass das passiert
wir müssen bloß aufhören glaube ich
immer so zu tun als wenn jetzt ist auch
die Regierung ich bin gar nicht jemand
der die Regierung da in Schutz nehmen
möchte wir müssen bloß immer sagen auch
wo wollen wir eigentlich dann im
Gegenzug sparen wenn wir uns darüber
beklagen dass äh und zurecht auch viele
Arbeitnehmer zu wenig netto haben dass
wir sagen die Pfleger verdienen alle zu
wenig ja hast du eine andere Lösung
verdient zum Teil über 4000 Euro nur mal
so als Beispiel ist ein median wert und
wir müssen immer sagen je mehr wir
fordern an das Gesundheitssystem das in
Deutschland durchaus sehr gut ausgebaut
ist
umso teurer werden die Kosten und die
Kosten die Kosten werden nie bezahlt
weil das Geld vom Himmel fällt sondern
werden immer von den Beitrag bezahlen
also wenn das heißt
bedeutet doch wissen wir wahrscheinlich
aus unseren Jobs auch immer dass man
mehr Macht als eine Arbeitskraft in
einem normalen 8 Stunden oder zehn
Stunden Dach hinbekommen bedeutet wenn
man das teilen möchte braucht man ein
zusätzlichen Pfleger kostet das ist
einfach so wobei wir müssen wobei wir
müssen wir müssen glaube ich da ein
bisschen
Licht ins Dunkle vielleicht bringen also
ich gebe Ihnen Recht die Pflege im
stationären Bereich wird nicht schlecht
bezahlt wir haben andere Pflege z.B im
ambulanten Bereich in der Altenpflege wo
wir immer noch ein großes Geld haben was
aber jetzt dazu natürlich gefüttert dass
wir extreme Verteuerungen jetzt gerade
haben
weil das da rief treuegesetz ja jetzt
gegriffen hat wir haben da
Herausforderung und ich bin völlig bei
ihnen Geld allein wird es nicht lösen
aber ich glaube schon dass wir Sachen an
der Struktur haben an die wir gehen
müssen zum Beispiel das Thema
Verbindlichkeit wenn ich heute mit
Pflegerinnen und Pfleger spreche und ich
mache das relativ häufig weil ich bin
pflegepolitischer Sprecher und die mir
erklären sie können keine zwei drei Tage
im Grunde im Voraus planen nicht wissen
ob sie den Dienst übernehmen müssen ob
genug Personal auf der Station ist dann
ist es ein Problem wir haben die
Demografie abwarten können wir wussten
wie viele Menschen in den Ruhestand
gehen das kann man berechnen das haben
wir nicht ausgeglichen und ich glaube
was wir auch machen müssen wir müssen
die Pflege auch wieder auf die Stufe
bringen wo sie wirklich pflegt wenn die
Frage nur früchtete und Kamillentee am
Bett ist dann ist es falsch es sind gut
ausgebildete Menschen die auch an den
Patient arbeiten müssen und damit auch
eine Wertschätzung haben also ich glaube
wir haben viele Strukturfragen in dem
Bereich das Problem ist uns tickt ein
bisschen die Zeit davon weil solange wir
so attraktiv haben wie jetzt kriegen wir
genau diese Situation dass immer die
Alarmglocken stellen müssen bevor wir
überhaupt handeln die 420 Millionen Euro
sind ein guter richtiger wichtiger
Schritt die personalbemessungsgrenze an
die gehen wir ja jetzt auch noch auf
bundesebenten pflegen und damit dass man
damit macht man nichts besser aber wir
werden auch und ähm da bin ich dann
wieder mehr bei Ihnen Herr Schäfer
sicherlich auch uns darüber unterhalten
müssen was wir uns in Zukunft leisten
können was wir uns nicht leisten können
und macht Karl Lauterbach jetzt ja auch
schon also
richtig man kann über Karl Lauterbach
ganz ganz viel sagen auch vieles
wahrscheinlich was der kritisch ist aber
er hat ja heute einen Plan vorgestellt
wir beispielsweise die
krankenhausfinanzen etwas stärker und
besser in den Griff bekommen möchte da
wird ein Ergebnis sein das ist
mutmaßlich nicht mehr so einfach ist in
das Krankenhaus um die Ecke zu gehen für
eine Spezial OP weil er sagt wir müssen
eher Zentren bilden also sag mal so für
Krebspatienten dann ist es eher das
Krankenhaus 100 km entfernt ich sehe
schon aber auch der Patient richtig ich
sehe schon da werden viele sagen oh
jetzt muss ich 100 km fahren das ist
dann so aber dafür bekomme ich
möglicherweise eine bessere Behandlung
auch weil dort einfach mehr Spezialisten
zum Beispiel